المدفعيه التركيه تكثف قصفها لتعلن
استهداف نحو 500 هدف منذ الاحد الماضي
تم الضرب
471 هدفا وتحيد
254 ارهابيا حتى الان بحسب متحدث كردي فان
مسيره تركيه اسادفت مقرا للقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه في قاعده روسيه تقع في شمال
شرق سوريا يوم الاحد اطلق تركيا عمليه
وقصف المدفع متواصل على مواقع لحزب العمال
الكردستاني في شمال العراق ووحدت حمايه
الشعب الكرديه في سوريا
الثلاثاء خصوصا على مدينه كوباني معقل
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه
المقاتلين الاكراد بالوقوف في وراء هجوم
اصفر عن سته قتله في الثالث عشر من نوفمبر
في اسطنبول رغم ان فيهما في كلمه امام
وبحسب العداله والتنميه الحاكم في
البرلمان اعلن الرئيس تركيا
في شمال سوريا هي مجرد بدايه
[موسيقى]
سوى ده يعني تركيا مصممه اليوم اكثر من اي
وقت مضى على حمايه حدودها مع سوريا
ولا يتوقفوا اردوغان عن التهديد بشني
عمليه بريه في شمال سوريا